[Music]
charles it's been um 70 years
since uh british monarch died
um i appreciate it's uh before your time
1952 but um perhaps using your
historical knowledge you could give us a
sense of
what a different country britain was and
the different position the monarchy was
in uh when queen elizabeth ii acceded to
the throne
um i think it's a bit misrepresented
what happened then um people now think
of it as incredibly old-fashioned and
which in a way it was but in another way
it wasn't because what it was was the
recovery
of confidence um
and
uh ceremony after the horrors of the
second world war
and it was of course a very young
monarch
so people were very excited in
it's also the first television event um
big public event on television in
british british history
and so it seemed very new though its
ritual was very ancient
um
and the fact that a
very young woman had become queen and in
fact become queen while
having holiday in
kenya
um was also part of
this this is a new thing hard to think
of that now it now seems almost
prehistoric when you watch the um
the the uh film but um it wasn't like
that at the time
yes the television uh aspect of her
reign is very important isn't it
it's hard to uh think of elizabeth ii
without thinking about television and so
i think british people actually started
to buy television so that they could see
the queen is that not right
that is correct yes and not many people
had television still so enormous numbers
of people i remember frank johnson the
spectator former editor it was an east
end boy telling me about how they were
crowded into his uncle's house in
shoreditch and sort of 40 of them all
sat around watching and they could
hardly see anything because a tiny tiny
screen poor film but terribly exciting
to watch it
james um there's already uh
some anxiety that uh the queen who was
this great unifying figure for the union
uh is now gone uh and that the glue that
bound the nation together if you like uh
is is is now has now vanished um
do you think unionists are right to be
concerned about the future
uh the queen obviously uh acted as a
kind of great unifying force and i think
the
mourning for her uh will will be
testament to that but i do think the
unifying figure of the monarchy will
will remain in
in in a different way in a different
form i think i think i think for king
charles it will be different
than it was for her
but i think i think he has uh he comes
to the crown relatively late in life
he's in his 70s and i think he will he
will bring
uh that experience and i think he is
wise enough to know
that as king he will have to be
to be more private about his opinions
than he was as prince of wales
charles are we about to see that um
because of course everybody talks about
how queen elizabeth represented
continuity are we about to see that
monarchy itself represents continuity
even more so perhaps than late green
i think so i think um
you shouldn't uh talk of the queen as um
as if it's a sort of one-off special
thing
and she would have been the last person
in the world who have wanted to see it
that way the point of the monarchical
system is that it's dynastic and all its
efforts go into perpetuating itself um
it has no other means of um survival and
the queen did that triumphantly um both
in terms of breeding so that we've got
this line stretching out before us for
you know what might be 100 years never
happened before
but also in terms of making the right
provisions so for example
she was very careful to ensure quite
recently actually that
then prince of wales would become head
of the commonwealth when she died
um she carefully
worked all that out
so i don't expect the crisis of monarchy
um
what i do think is will obviously be
difficult in the short term is that our
whole way of thinking about british
monarchy
has been very governed by this reign
because it's so successful and so long
and um
some rethinking will require i'll just
make one point there which is that now
that the queen is dead the person with
the by far the longest experience of
public life anywhere in the whole of the
world
is the new king
he has been um he's been an active
figure on the international stage for
more than 50 years
james what do you think was the most uh
precarious moment perhaps of elizabeth's
reign because there were moments of
christ crisis crises
uh in the 70s and 80s um
what where do you where do you think she
had her most difficult period as monarch
i i think there are two
1992 the anna's herbalist and then 1997
are after the death of diana princess of
wales when i i think the queen in her
desire to to protect understandable
disaster protect her own family
kind of misread the public mood and uh
and i think i think in some ways
that was that was a very difficult
moment for the monarchy given how
emotionally volatile the country was at
that point but i think what stands out
to me is that in this 70 year reign that
the the longest in british history you
know those uh
though those mistakes are so much
smaller than the equivalent mistakes
made by queen victoria when you think
about the the bed chamber crisis or um
or queen victoria's withdrawal from
public life after prince albert's death
charles do you think um after the death
of diana and obviously there was a
tumult there uh that queen elizabeth
and the monarchy in fact came out
stronger because of it
i do think so i think it was um
it was difficult but really the
profound difficulty lasted for five days
it was from the princess died on a
sunday the trouble began on monday and
the queen calmed it by her broadcast on
the friday and the funeral was the
following day
and um
actually um
the queen was perhaps slow off the mark
in seeing exactly how you would need to
deal with this question but when she did
see in this very very short period she
got absolutely right on that friday with
her broadcast and brought the nation
together in time for the funeral so
i don't think even if she got that wrong
it would have been ultimately disastrous
and i certainly didn't agree with the
people at the time or later who say that
it's written demonically but i think um
it was it was difficult it did show up
some real problems um
and it was the nearest we ever got to
quite strong public criticism of the
queen um
all those things were important but all
those things were overcome
charles i wanted to end by asking you
about the queen's faith because she was
a devout christian
in an age that uh is often called
post-christian
um how important do you think was
religion to the way the queen looked at
the world and the way the queen uh
behaved as a monarch
i think it was absolutely central to the
queen's approach and not only because
she took her role as supreme governor of
church england very seriously
but for more profound uh
reasons um that was her faith
um and she had a particular type of
christian faith which is very acquired
but is all pervading
so each day
she prayed every night and she each
sunday she attended church
and she was very much of that school i
think which doesn't want to talk about
it but does want to do it and to
practice this more than to preach
whenever she did preach which was very
very slightly at her christmas broadcast
the name of jesus would usually come in
and the christmas message in some way
would always come in a christian message
at christmas and um
i think it explains the way she did so
much by stealth
you have to think in order to understand
the queen you have to understand
the
things you didn't quite see or that she
didn't quite say as much as the things
that she did
and
that's very characteristic of a certain
humble christianity which is you're not
showing off you don't matter as yourself
it's your duty to god in your neighbor
that matters and that's that gives a
life lifelong
sustaining power
do you think her religious instincts
were perhaps more low church than uh you
might expect from a head of the church
um maybe but i i think it's very
important that the queen didn't have
was absolutely uninterested in religious
parties and factions in fact
um you know would have regarded them as
a very very bad news and um
this also explains attitude to other
faiths
um and other denominations of
christianity um
nobody could ever she was a strong
quite old-fashioned protestant anglican
but nobody could ever say she was trying
to sort of advance that in some
argumentative or disparaging way against
anyone else and she famously
formulated the doctrine that the church
of england could be a sort of umbrella
for other denominations and other faiths
and i that was very clearly recognized
by jews and muslims and so on um
she she understood that
um
if she was going to follow in the
footsteps of jesus which in her quiet
way she was trying to do
she must always show love and respect
for people not
be disapproving of them
james we now have a new king
and britain will now have to think about
the role of the church of england
in
public life
do you think we will now see a monarchy
that has to concentrate more on its on
the religious aspect and and and the
sacred aspects of it
i i think the coronation will obviously
bring those things to the fore
uh i i think though that uh as charles
said i think i think the church of
england has it is the church of the
country and i think that i think the
royal family's done a very astute job of
you know
for all the divisions within the
anglican communion on all sorts of
issues the royal family's done a very
astute job of of avoiding getting drawn
into those
charles
you knew the queen a little bit uh
there's going to be a lot of talk about
her character what she was really like
and so on but i wonder if you could tell
us
is there an aspect of her personality
that you think the public uh misses
well
no i think i think her integrity was
apparent what i think it perhaps needs
emphasis
which i find in a way the most
extraordinary thing about it is
her absolute lack of vanity
um here you are um
all your life and certainly from when
you knew you were going to be
uh out of the throne people have been
flattering you
every single day
so she probably has received flattery
for
96 years i don't think one little bit of
it went to her head i don't think she
ever thought aren't i clever aren't i
brilliant gosh didn't i do well aren't i
beautiful et cetera none of really none
of those things at all she had an inner
dignity and therefore an inner
self-confidence
but literally no vanity and that's the
most extraordinary achievement i think i
can't think of anyone famous who's like
that
charles james thank you very much indeed
[Music]
you